c'est ce que je ne voulais pas la
dernière fois je ne suis pas venu pour
faire un débat avec 17 personnes je suis
venu démentir et je suis venu aussi pour
parler de mon livre vous plaît merci
voilà merci francis en tout cas d'avoir
été là non mais heureusement on doit
parler de mon activité artistique
exactement là c'est parce que moi non
mais sur du texte qui a bouleversé jean
paul ii dim
alors je vais dire simplement quelque
chose moi je suis un artiste
ainsi une personne qui a pris de la
force avec qq mme b alors ma langue a
fourché
c'était pour sa partie face d'humour ça
va rester ça alors alors moi je suis si
on me laisse parler je suis donc une
personne qui a pris dans la société
d'énormes risques personnels je me suis
exposé pour porter la parole de tous les
gens qu'il ne désire pas se soumettre à
la pensée unique
mais je reste un artiste je reste un
artiste j'ai essuyé beaucoup d' injure
au coût de calomnies et notamment parmi
les calomnies on dit que je je ne suis
plus dans ce métier
alors c'est faux je suis dans plusieurs
métiers ma tournée de 130 date si elle a
été arrêtée
c'est pas parce qu'ils avaient pas de
monde c'est parce qu'il ya eu là
qu'ovide et donc comme tous les artistes
j'ai été obligé d'arrêter ma tournée de
130 date mais j'ai d'autres projets
artistiques le premier projet artistique
que j'ai c'est ce livre le journal de
joseph qui sort aujourd'hui la risle or
aujourd'hui en librairie est une
réédition et qui est un livre dans
lequel je parle de la paternité est un
thème qui me ferait un meilleur et aussi
de ma foi chrétienne puisque je suis
chrétien et et que et que ma foi c'est
très important et nous notamment dans la
foi chrétienne on
on rejette la violence donc en tant que
chrétien je ne peux pas me livrer à
aucune violence
ensuite j'ai un autre projet artistique
c'est je vais signer ça c'est de la
violence
ça c'est de la violence pour rigoler
c'est rigolo à son score si francis ça
c'est de la vraie violence alors ensuite
ensuite j'ai un autre projet artistique
d'un autre projet artistique
merci déjà notre projet artistique est
un disque que je vais enregistrer chez
universal il faut savoir que léo ferré a
été mon maître et mon ami pendant 15 ans
et plus avant de mourir il avait projeté
d'enregistrer un album et que cet album
il n'a pas pu l'enregistrer parce qu'il
est mort ces deux rives
ça c'est pas moi pas de sécu qu'une
béquille voilà parce qu'ils ne
connaissent tout ce qui fait donc
français souillée et donc si j'étais en
train de salles en plus et là c'est la
maison mais j'étais en train de parler
de la mort d'un grand succès ah oui ça
peut être bien aussi à ce moment là que
tu m'écoutes je t'écoute de rire au
moment où je parle de la mort de
quelqu'un ça marche je t'écoute
fous-rires c'est bon c'est la dernière
et donc tu vas tu vas faire un album
[Applaudissements]
sortez allez pas les prendre le pouls ya
un port pour la dernière
allez hop ou sans rigoler à léo pour
aller au pot à léopold 3,6 alors voilà
c'est bien si on reste tous les deux
voilà merci france voilà donc sensible
en veux-tu que je suis fan de léo ferré
c'était jure que c'est vrai voilà tu
comprends que ça puisse me choquer ce
qui vient de se passer pour moi ça c'est
de la vraie violence c'est non et si si
si ça ce qui vient de se passer là pour
moi c'est une vraie violence
ce que j'ai subi avec ces gens là c'est
de la violence alors on assimile la
violence simplement aux cookies sont
donnés mais je pense que l'irrespect si
une forme de violence est alors je vais
parler de ce disque donc magie francis
tchèques eux se disent que c'est le
disque que léo ferré était sur le point
d'enregistrer vous voulez pas je vais
reprendre a dit francis c'est dingue
alors quand il met alors les césar alors
oui paris france organise à la peau
alors donc non je suis sûr que ces
paysages bon d'accord non écoute 106,1
ses longs tubes mais ô surprise
non allez hop on est allé au pot oui oui
oui
allez hop alors francis suivez-moi
paraître aussi ça moi je rigole pas il
ya un trop long s'il vous plaît est ce
qu on peut juste dire à eric meyer et
sylvie ortega qu'on battrait à l'entrée
qu'on l'ait pas ce que pense ici a dit
francis excuse-moi léo ferré qui était
mon maître et mon ami pendant 15 ans
avait le projet
non rien
allez ouais christie
[Applaudissements]
mettez-vous la demande à côté on laisse
ces populations que vous êtes magnifique
voix ouais francis nous on adore son
fils alain et moi 106 en fait c'est un
numéro que tu es en train de faire du
tout d'accord parce qu'ils étaient
invités après toi donc je leur dit on
n'aura pas le pas puisque on a pris trop
de temps mais je sais c'est pas grave
alors quoi ce souhait dont il était prêt
à la rentrée était prévu que j'en parle
mais il n'était pas prévu que j'en parle
et tu fasses un numéro en même temps oui
bon d'accord avec ça alors français que
je vais reprendre ce que je disais avec
gentillesse et patience merci mon chéri
voilà il faut que tu te détendre aussi
un peu france et non mais non excuse moi
excusez moi pour voir des gens rire
quand je parle de la mort d'une
reddition n'a pas effectué offert et on
respecte tous ceux-là d'or c'est très
bien alors alors je te dire un mot avec
lui tu vas tu énervé en temps mais parce
que tu me dis on ne respecte pas un
artiste se respecte est offert et
j'adore ce qu'il fait habitat moria un
quart d'heure non mais non mais et alors
parce qu'il est mort il ya un énorme
mais si on ne rigole pas de la mort de
l'eau ferrer non on est en rigole de
kelkoo coup mais d'accord voilà est-ce
que c'est possible si vous rirez
terminée oui bien donc
léo ferré qui était mon maître et mon
ami pendant 15 ans avant de mourir avait
prévu d'enregistrer un album
d'accord cet album la famille de léo m'a
demandé c'est de l'enregistrer donc je
vais être la voix de l'est au sur cet
album c'est un album qui va sortir à la
rentrée est le dernier projet que j'ai
pour l'instant
outre celui de reprendre ma tournée
bonjour mademoiselle mais faute ça c'est
que à la rentrée donc chez bertin au
parc au théâtre du gymnase à paris
je vais donc jouer le rôle de pablo
escobar dans une pièce oui dans une
pièce de bentiaba rendrait bendjaber qui
s'appelle l'homme dont la mère était la
mort et la mise en scène sera de jean
luc moreau
non c'est non voilà donc je voulais
rassurer tous les
[Applaudissements]